نعم حتى هذه اللحظه التي اتحدث معك بها
هناك اصوات اشتباكات واضحه في الاجزاء
الشرقيه لمحافظه خانيونس وكذلك اصوات
الانفجارات لا نعلم ان كان هذا الخبر
متعلق بهذه الاشتباكات او في مناطق اخرى
من المناطق الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه خاصه ان
قطاع غزه ما زال ساحه حرب وساحه ايضا
مواجهات ما بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وكذلك
قوات الاحتلال التي تتوغل في اكثر من
منطقه من قطاع غزه سواء في الشمال حتى في
وسط غزه وكذلك جنوب قطاع غزه
منذ اصوات انفجارات تسمع في هذه اللحظات
في الاجزاء في الاجزاء الشماليه الشرقيه
لمحافظه خيان يونس واطلاق النار لم يتوقف
منذ اكثر من ساعتين من الرشاشات الثقيله
تطلقها اليات الاحتلال وايضا الطائرات
المروحيه قبل قليل حلقت في الاجزاء
الشماليه الشرقيه للمحافظه في خانون جنوب
قطاع غزه واطلقت النار ايضا في ظل ايضا
تحركات لاليات الاحتلال في اكثر من منطقه
في خانيونس مع يعني رفع الليل غطائه وظهور
اي يعني ضوء الصباح يعني كشفت عن اعم
الدخان تتصاعد في هذه اللحظات ونشاهدها
الان بالعين المجرده اعمده الدخان تتصاعد
في هذه اللحظات في الاجزاء الشرقيه
لمحافظه خانيونس ايضا وميض هذه الانفجارات
التي تسمع بين الحين والاخر نشاهدها وايضا
هناك حرار على ما يبدو في تلك المناطق
التي يتم قصفها من قبل اليات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في المناطق التي تتوغل فيها
لكن عموما فيما يتعلق باليه الاحتلال كان
هناك حديث متواتر من قبل المواطنين وكذلك
بعض شهود الاعيان بان هناك تراجع لبعض
الاليات من المناطق التي توغلت فيها خاصه
في وسط محافظه خانيونس باتجاه الشمال
انسحبت وه منطقه الشمال شمال خانيونس يعني
ان هناك مح مور لانسحاب اليات الاحتلال
باتجاه المناطق الشرقيه الشماليه لمحافظه
خانيونس وهناك حديث عن تراجعات لكن هذه
المعلومه لا نستطيع تاكيدها ممكن تاكيدها
بعد ساعات من من من هذه من هذه اللحظه
خاصه مع تحرك المواطنين في كثير من
الاحياء مع ساعه الصباح الى تلك المناطق
وهم ايضا يفيدون به ب مثل هذه الاخبار لكن
الاطلاق النار مستمر اطلاق القذائف مستمر
في الاجزاء والاطراف الشرقيه الشماليه
لمحافظه خانيونس في منطقه وسط محافظه
خانيونس خفت حده هذه الانفجارات وكذلك
عمليه اطلاق النار لكن انتقلت الى المناطق
الشماليه من وسط المحافظه تحديدا في شارع
خمسه الذي هو يعتبر مسرح لعمليات واليات
الاحتلال التي تقوم في هذه اللحظات كما
نسمع في خلفيه الصوت باطلاق النار حتى هذه
اللحظه بشكل جنوني وكثيف جدا جدا باتجاه
منازل المواطنين في بعض المنازل في تلك
المنطقه يتواجد بها مواطنون هناك مواطنون
عالقون و محاصرون تحت النيران في هذه
اللحظات في تلك المنطقه اضافه الى ان
امتداد شارع خمسه في نها في في الجزء في
الجزء الاخير منه من الناحيه الغربيه
هناك يعني مقر لوكاله الامم المتحده يعرف
بمقر الصناعه تحديدا ويوجد به نازحون يعني
الالاف من النازحين متواجدون داخل هذا
المقر والطلقات الناريه في كثير من
الاحيان قد اصابت هذا المقر خاصه من الجهه
الشرقيه لهذا المقر نشاهد في هذه اللحظات
وميض ايضا انفجار على ما يبدو سنسمع او
سيسمع في هذه اللحظات انفجار جديد نعم هذا
الانفجار ناتج عن قصف من قبل مدفعيه
الاحتلال في هذه اللحظات والقصف المدفعي
لم يتوقف منذ منتصف الليله وحتى هذه
اللحظه مع ساعات الصباح ايضا لم يتوقف
نتحدث عن اكثر من ست ساعات والقصف المدفعي
واطلاق النار ايضا مستمر ومتواصل في
الاجزاء الشماليه الشرق لمحافظه خانيونس
وكذلك المناطق الشرقيه لمحافظه خانيونس
تحديدا في خانيونس في المنطقه الشرقيه
منطقه بني سهيله ومنطقه الزنه في تلك
المدينه بالحديث عن الاوضاع عموما في قطاع
غزه وخاصه الاجزاء الجنوبيه من قطاع غزه
في منطقه رفح كان هناك خلال هذه الليله
قصف من قبل طائرات الاحتلال لمنازل
مواطنين خاصه في منطقه حي جنينه وتم
استهداف منزلين واعلن عن استشهاد احد
المواطنين واصابه العشرات من المواطنين
نتيجه هذا القصف الى ايضا وسط قطاع غزه في
مدينه دير البلح ثلاثه منازل لمواطنين تم
استهدافها و تنفيذ غارات من قبل طائرات
الاحتلال ادى ذلك الى استشهاد عدد من
المواطنين واصابه ايضا عدد اخر من
المواطنين وصفت حالات بعضهم بالحرجه جدا
اطلاق النار مستمر حتى الان اعمده الدخان
ما زالت تتصاعد في هذه اللحظات
والانفجارات بين الحين والاخر ونرى ايضا
وميد هذم الناريه التي تطلق من اسلحه
رشاشه ثقيله من قبل اليات الاحتلال امامنا
وهي تتحرك باتجاه مناطق مختلفه سواء في
شمال او شرق محافظه خان يونس